so this question is dr. mather did the
results of cosmological research imply
any constraints on the progress of
particle physics in the future and I
think the answer is not yet we that have
measured the properties of the Big Bang
material have a few mysteries that are
open and we hope that future particle
physics results will help us explain
them we think that we're supporting the
inflationary theory of the Big Bang and
we hope to learn a little bit more about
the Big Bang eventually particle physics
we hope will explain quantum gravity and
why the Big Bang material did what it
did so far this is a hope it's not
obviously something that particle
physics will be called on to explain
when we ever get to the place where we
think that we have a theory of all the
particles it will have to understand and
explain the Big Bang can this happen I
don't know but we're certainly hoping
for it